et on va accueillir notre quatrième et
dernière invité politique et c'est hervé
Juvin bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous des petites européens conseiller
régional du rassemblement national dans
les Pays de la Loire Hervé juin le
rassemblement national selon les
projections sera largement derrière la
France insoumise en nombre de députés
vous ne serez pas la première force
d'opposition Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
vous avez échoué à transformer les sets
de la présidentielle je ne pense pas
vous venez de le dire par rapport aux
élections de 2017 nous gagnons un
pourcentage significatif de voix environ
4 à 5% ce qui représente plus d'un
million d'électeurs il y a beaucoup de
chance que nous puissions former un
groupe je suis prudent sur ce sujet
parce que la particularité du scrutin un
inominal à deux tours c'est que c'était
extraordinairement difficile de faire
des projections en siège j'entends les
uns et les autres d'ailleurs à mon avis
de manière bien risquée essayez de
prévoir combien ils auront députés dans
une semaine pour ma part je serai très
prudent sur le sujet vous craignez
encore
à peu près tous vos confrères à peu près
tous les médias ont voulu nous raconter
que nupes avait le Ventoux que nups
allaient devancer en marche et que nupet
était la force qui allait l'emporter je
constate quoi au lendemain du premier
tour nous pèse et d'un petit peu
derrière en marche donc il a raté son
pari nupes fait beaucoup moins bien que
le total des parties de gauche à la
présidentielle totale des parties de
gauche proche de 31% du pèse à 25 donc
c'est un échec pour Monsieur Mélenchon
Monsieur Mélenchon contrairement à ce
que nous a raconté n'a aucune chance
d'être Premier ministre et je vais vous
dire une chose moi je crois qu'au cours
de la semaine en entendant les
propositions de la nupesse le blocage
des prix le recrutement de centaines de
milliers de fonctionnaires qu'est-ce
qu'on va leur donner à faire etc je
pense qu'Emmanuel Macron va avoir la
majorité absolue au Parlement de fait ce
pari je pense qu'Emmanuel Macron aura la
majorité absolue au Parlement parce que
les Français a juste titre ou être
inquiets d'un certain nombre des
propositions de nupes est-ce que est-ce
que ce projet les résultats de ce
premier tour vous même pas quelques
regrets malgré tout quand on voit la
façon dont Marine Le Pen a débuté sa
campagne des législatives absente
pendant deux semaines et puis quand elle
est arrivée elle a pris acte que de fait
Emmanuel Macron aurait sa majorité dans
la logique institutionnelle quand vous
voyez les résultats aujourd'hui vous
dites pas on aurait dû faire peut-être
différemment je suis désolé mais je vais
être d'un avis rigoureusement contraire
regardez à quoi servir Éric Zemmour les
millions des pensées pour le grand
meeting du Trocadéro c'était à grand
bruit ça n'a pas marché regardez
Emmanuel Macron qui est en aucun cas n'a
fait campagne finalement en marche et de
semble-t-il un peu devant du Pesse et
finalement en marche se débrouille pas
mal dans ce premier tour contrairement à
ce qu'on pouvait à ce qu'on pouvait
attendre je pense que la campagne a
favori du rassemblement national a fort
bien fonctionné Emmanuel Macron il a
appelé les Français à lui donner une
majorité claire et forte Marine Le Pen
elle a dit de toute façon c'est Emmanuel
Macron
vous êtes d'accord avec moi en marche
arrière
est-ce que en disant de toute façon les
campagnes pas bruit ben ça je pense que
les Français ne croient plus aux grands
déferlement puisque Jean-Luc Mélenchon
d'emploi ce mot je crois que les
Français ne croient plus aux grands
déferlement de grands meeting de grandes
manipulations médiatiques etc et
j'observe que les deux forces politiques
ont fait campagne à bas bruit ça
fonctionne bien si je parle de ma région
les Pays de la Loire dans la Sarthe il y
avait cinq circonscriptions nous avons
des candidats dans 4 au second tour et
ainsi suivre que vous n'aviez quand même
pas cité c'est que le rassemblement
national va être présent dans 208 duels
208 de l sur 580 c'est extraordinaire
c'est 208 208 duel 406 pour la Nupe nous
disait Eric Coquerel tout à l'heure Vous
contestez le fait que la nuque soit un
succès mais cette union des gauches elle
est redoutablement efficace pour se
qualifier pour le second tour est-ce que
ça vous donne pas des regrets par
rapport à Eric Zemmour le fait d'avoir
refusé la main tendue par Eric Zemmour
au soir de sa défaite vous savez qu'en
politique les alliances c'est jamais
plus plus deux et deux font en politique
quelquefois 2 et 2 font 3 il arrive même
que 2 et 2 ça fait un et demi
il y a un certain nombre de choses que
Éric Zemmour avec beaucoup de talents et
beaucoup de convictions mettent en avant
qui correspondent à la droite patriote à
la droite nationale que nous
représentons et puis un certain nombre
de points sur lesquels nous ne sommes
pas d'accord et un certain nombre de
points peut-être une France nostalgie
peut-être une France dont on pense que
ça n'est plus la France moderne ce n'est
plus la France dans laquelle aspire à
vivre les Français que représentait Éric
Zemmour il ne fallait pas en s'alliant à
Éric Zemmour que nous perdions une
partie essentielle de notre électorat
est-ce que vous n'avez pas perdu votre
seule réserve de voir les alliances avec
Éric Zemmour non parce que je vous le
disais la porosité est forte
dans ce qu'il serait convenu d'appeler
le mot est très désuet les couches
populaires ces Français ont du mal à y
arriver ces Français ont peur de voir le
prix de l'essence monté ces français
qu'on peut de la montée des prix
alimentaires ces Français qui sont très
conscients qu'on a encore rien vu et que
le pire de la crise est dire en
septembre et en octobre et je pense
qu'au second tour une partie des
Français qui se rendent compte que si
tous les pouvoirs sont donnés à Emmanuel
Macron il y a que le rassemblement
national qui les
protègement pour vous c'est une bonne
nouvelle qui soit pas présent à
l'assemblée je pense que suite été
compliqué parce que je pense qu'Eric
Zemmour aurait porté à l'Assemblée une
parole à laquelle nous n'adhérons pas et
une parole qui aura induit en erreur
beaucoup de Français est-ce que ça peut
faciliter le fait d'enterrer l'âge de
guerre après les législatives on
entendait sur notre antenne hier soir
Thierry Mariani dire que il faudrait
peut-être penser quand même à recoller
les morceaux à un moment je pense que
les morceaux n'ont pas été brisés je
pense que le camp patriote le camp de
ceux qui pensent que la France c'est
leur premier patrimoine et c'est d'abord
la France qui compte pour eux je pense
que ce camp-là va se retrouver
et d'appareil je parle des lecteurs je
ne parle pas d'élus ou je ne parle pas
de force politique constituée hors de
question de temps de la main avec
Zemmour après les législatives leurs
électeurs se retrouveront tout
naturellement avec les nôtres et
justement se posent la question
maintenant de qui va voter pour qui au
second tour notamment dans les
circonscriptions où il y a des duels
entre le rassemblement et la nuque ça
concerne 58 circonscriptions on va
écouter ce que disait ce matin Olivia
Grégoire la porte-parole du gouvernement
elle était l'invité de RTL dans ces cas
précis RN nupet soyons très clair pas
une seule voie pour le rassemblement
national pas une seule voie pour le
rassemblement national c'est la position
de la majorité présidentielle
nous n'avons jamais manquer de clarté à
l'endroit de ce sujet nous sommes clairs
comme de l'eau de roche pas une voix
pour un projet de fermeture un projet
que nous n’estimons pas être bon pour le
pays
le système garde du système Olivia
Grégoire représente le système elle sait
bien qu'elle est chiante du système la
nupes ceux qui protège le système
existant
et ne tout naturellement l'Union se fait
parce que la force de changement et la
véritable opposition c'est le
rassemblement national c'est propos ne
me surprennent absolument pas ce sont
les propos constants qu'on entend depuis
longtemps j'observe simplement que ces
propos n'ont rien empêché le
rassemblement national de progresser
élections après élections et de faire
que de plus en plus de Français s'y
retrouve vous lis intervenir Olivier ou
quand non je j'avais juste en tête une
une interrogation sur vous dites les le
parti des forces populaires le
rassemblement national mais il
semblerait quand même que nups de ce
point de vue obtienne des résultats
notamment auprès des salariés ou des
Français les moins fortunés aujourd'hui
ils sont au-dessus de vous semble-t-il
dans la sociologie électorale parce
qu'il y a pas de ce point de vue du fait
de l'évolution de votre positionnement
une évolution aussi de votre de votre
électorat et deuxièmement vous dites
campagne à bas bruit ça marche mais
est-ce que vous n'avez pas justement
chez les populaire et notamment chez les
jeunes à faire campagne pour les
mobiliser ce qu'a su faire Jean-Luc
Mélenchon la nups est-ce que vous n'avez
vous pas fait cette fois-ci pour
législatives et le défi de répondre en
moins de 30 secondes s'il vous plaît sur
la campagne à bas bruit Marine Le Pen a
fait remarquablement bien pour les
présidentielles et partout sur les
marchés etc oui ça a bien marché nous
avons continué à le faire nous candidats
beaucoup de gens très jeunes d'ailleurs
qui représentent l'avenir l'ont fait à
l'occasion de cette élection législative
et je pense que ça se retrouve dans les
208 duels dans lesquelles nous ont
présents sur la l'autre question
la gauche n'est pas morte c'est une des
conclusions de cette élection on a voulu
dire que le clivage gauche droite
n'existait plus c'est faux en revanche
il y a un clivage qui montre très
clairement c'est celui des métropoles
par rapport au territoire oublié de la
République c'est probablement là que
nous sommes les plus forts l'union de
couches populaires problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat problème d'emploi inquiétude
pour l'avenir avec les territoires
oubliés de la République c'est là que
nous allons faire alliance Hervé
circonscriptions le rassemblement
national n'est pas présent au deuxième
tour nous laissons la liberté de
conscience à nos électeurs qu'il vote
pour le candidat ou pour la candidate
qui leur semble le mieux représenté les
idées patriotiques et les plus attachés
à la force
Marine Le Pen et Jordan Bardella
ça peut être abstention ou ça peut être
vote pour les candidats les plus
patriote représentants l'intérêt
national merci beaucoup Hervé juin merci
d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]